vado da mi dia ai ragazzi se siete
capitati qui è perché ci tenete al
vostro corpo e alla vostra salute
ricordate sempre di riscaldarvi prima di
ogni allenamento perché è
importantissimo prevenire gli infortuni
e arrivare belli caldi fare porno
[Musica]
facciamo subito un po di immobili
particolare per preparare il nostro
corpo a quello che andremo a fare che
neanche io so perché ancora non
l'abbiamo registrato non l'abbiamo
girato però questo sarà un po un
riscaldamento che potrebbe essere usato
per qualsiasi tipo di allenamento che
facciamo
va bene allora partiamo dal collo cir
conduzioni 12345678 cambio fatelo finché
non ti si fa svenire 4 5 6 7 8 ma
sentite questa leggera brezza di
svarione è normale cir conduzione anche
la vera le 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 c e conduzioni
delle spalle 3 4 5 6 7 ott kang u 23
78 potremmo fare un po di pampini papi
ok spalle in questo modo qui ok
noi vogliamo anche lateralmente via via
via via o ragazzi e mobilità articolare
vi auguriamo sui gomiti che stava fatto
esclusivamente così sennò non funziona e
lavoriamo ancora gomito gesto
all'italiana e spingo e spingo tre
posizioni 1 2 e 3 3 gomiti via cambio 12
infine dentro spingo e spingo non
ritengo l'orologio a destra cir
conduzioni del busto superiore e blocco
il bacino sguardo sempre in camera la
prorompente via e cir conduzioni della
metà sottostante cambio cir conduzioni
dall'altra parte di vari un po le gambe
sguardo vediamo giu sentite femorale
un due tre qua c'è mi sposto su una
gamba 3
qua c'è disposto sull'altra
adesso sono diventati cinque movimenti
prima erano otto sono sempre a 8 anche
se io vado sull'altra campo 1 2 3 qua
c'è 6 sett ott cambio 13 quantici 7
spingo bene spingo bene con il bacino e
mi raccomando vado zucchero un po le
gambe e sciolgo anche anca e ginocchio
ginocchio anca e ginocchio anche di un
geologo un po le che le titolazioni
ginocchia e caviglie pumping questo
aiuta anche nel tuo herck via faccio
vedere anche profilato è free scendiamo
giù nuovamente ad una gamba
vado sull'altra
mi siedo giu porto giu ginocchio mano e
mi risollevo super uguale 12 41 24
cambio è dovuto 1 3 4 1 2 3 4 sul
braccio e porto a te braccio nel porto a
te braccio e porto a te braccio e porto
a te sciolgo vado giù mi siedo sciolgo
anche anche via via porto super tendine
sentite qua una lombarda cambio i
sollevo il tallone io do inganno
apro divaricata frontale 123 e cir
conduzione completa da un lato
dall'altro ping obbligati le mani a
terra cane a testa in giù giù i talloni
e carico e polsi vado giù essendo nella
posizione del serpente prorompente
privato su privato nel cane a testa in
giù da qui torno su cane a testa in giù
vado giù via di nuovo serpente
prorompente vedete stiamo iniziando a
sudare il mio bypass ci sta è una cosa
particolare il corpo puoi muoverti puoi
fare fesso resti freddo come inizia a
lavorare sulle articolazioni tutto
prende vita tutto un fuoco rialzo
sistema il pantaloncino della pipa e
siamo pronti possiamo partire